[Musique]
oh mon dieu
on est vraiment désolé je sais une
manuelle sais tu comment conduire ça on
est tellement desmond tutu comment
changer les vitesses mois et on a plus
qu on abandonner
[Musique]
on veut seulement vous parlez de votre
conjoint il m'a donc pays d'où était de
la cia excusez moi des gens très méchant
mais cherche et maintenant ils sont été
trop quoi tout ça se produit peut-être
parce qu'ils étaient sortis avec un
espion table à tort
c'est une clé usb tu dois la vallée
avant qu'il revienne à eau
on peut plus revenir en arrière on est
rendus semi professionnel
professionnel on est des professionnels
accroche toi
oh mon dieu je suis quelqu'un tu as kaka
et de gris je pose question si je n'aime
pas réponse tu as mal je vais vous dire
tout ce que vous voulez j'ai jamais
gardé un secret de toute ma vie
audrey c'est pile à crack de boulez de
cure les dents avec ses cheveux elle
fait des rêves érotiques avec des
mignons c'est seulement le mignon qui
ajuste annuel à google et sur mon
ordinateur et maintenant je reçois plein
de blizzard
[Musique]